[Music]
[Applause]
mr burnt i expect you to die
are y'all forgetting one thing if i fail
to report another bond replaces me
i trust he will be more successful
what are you doing what are you doing oh
oh no no
well at least he died on the job
from now on all remaining agents and
trainees be known as james bond double o
seven including the girls well that'd be
right confusing so exactly the enemy
won't know which way to turn my name's
bond
james bond
my name is london
james bond
you should give up smoking
cigarettes are very bad for your chest
looks like you have about two seconds to
live
my name's bob
james
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
knocking off [ __ ]
[Music]
who are you
bond james bond
who are you
james bond
the key to a woman's heart is an
unexpected gift
name's bond
james bond
[Music]
[Music]
bond here
yes of course i'm back
i've just tweeted an apology
honey
[Music]
james bond
[Music]
corridor digital.com is a website that
we have built for all of you who like
watching our videos it puts them up ad
free and nice clean premium viewing
experience basically we're not trying to
get between you and the videos with
algorithms and playlists and auto plays
and ads and all that stuff and also
there's some exclusive shows like the
vlogs inside of a dungeon which is
coming out very soon it's gonna be very
cool all right thank you
quarterdigital.com so long